hattet ihr schon mal 30 Stunden
Beziehungskrach und musste dann so tun
als sei alles super nee die schon ich
bin sehr sehr froh über diese Gespräche
man schweigt sich auseinander und man
diskutiert sich zusammen wie oft war es
denn diesen Verhandlungen zwei gegen
einen also SPD und FDP gegen sie ist
doch egal also Mammutsitzung im
Kanzleramt und der riesige streitpunkt
war die Verkehrspolitik da gab es viel
Ärger und viele sitzungsunterbrechungen
und jetzt gibt es massive Kritik Luisa
Neubauer von Fridays for future schreibt
es ist unfassbar also unfassbar schlecht
was da entschieden wurde und ruft gleich
auf zum nächsten sonderstreik vor dem
Verkehrsministerium was macht die Ampel
da beim Thema Auto und wer darf dabei
nur hinten sitzen warum ist
Verkehrsminister Wissing so ein Wut
Magnet geworden und haben die wütenden
recht Zeit für ein inside politics
einsteigen bitte
[Applaus]
mein Name ist Bernd Benthin ich kümmere
mich im Hauptstadtstudio um die
Umweltpolitik um FDP und Grüne und das
heißt ich kümmere mich seit Monaten auch
ums Auto und ich möchte mit euch auf
drei Punkte schauen warum tobt in der
Ampel ein Kulturkampf ums Auto was ist
der Kern des Streits und wer setzt sich
gerade warum durch es geht um das ewige
gespenstempolimit um Anton Hofreiter und
es geht auch um diesen bekennenden
Autofan
Christian Lindner ist der Chef von
Verkehrsminister Wissing und er liebt
Autos mit 19 hat sich Lindner den ersten
Porsche gekauft ein gebrauchten Boxster
in schwarz warum fragt ihr ein ich den
denn das Geräusch das Motorgeräusch des
Boxermotors Liebe weil ich gerne
forciert durch den Verkehr gleite schon
2017 hat Lindner der Fachzeitschrift
Auto Motor Sport ein Interview gegeben
und seine Verkehrspolitik skizziert aus
heutiger Sicht ließ sich das wie das
prophezeite FDP Regierungsprogramm
erstens Autobahn nicht nur planen
sondern auch bauen zweitens keine
Diskriminierung des Diesels drittens
keine Volkserziehung durch Tempolimit
und viertens keine Fixierung auf
E-Mobilität sondern
technologieoffenheit und wenn Olaf
Scholz das Wort Deutschland Tempo liebt
dann liebt die FDP dieses Wort
technologieoffenheit
technologieoffenheit Technologie
Offenheit also das Stichwort ist
technologieoffenheit habe jetzt auch das
Schlagwort beim Streit um das sogenannte
Verbrenner aus die EU will dass ab 2035
nur noch Elektroautos zugelassen werden
heißt im Klartext alle sollen dann ihre
bis dahin gebauten Verbrenner weiter
fahren dürfen es sollen bloß keine neuen
mehr gebaut werden Volker Wissing hat
aber mit ziemlicher Härte und penetrans
durchgesetzt das ist noch ein ja
Hintertürchen für den klassischen
Verbrennermotor gibt dann mit
klimafreundlichem Kraftstoff den ifuels
auch wenn du ganz wenige glauben dass es
die ja wirklich bringen werden das ganze
Theater nützt in erster Linie der FDP E4
sind nichts weiter als Wahlkampf Klimbim
sie sind ineffizient und teuer sehr sehr
aufwendig herzustellen wie viele davon
Gebrauch machen und ob das überhaupt
relevant wird das kann niemand sagen
aber nicht nur bei den efields tun sich
in der Ampel Straßengräben auf in der
Verkehrspolitik bekämpfen sich Grüne und
FDP an allen Ecken und Enden mit Worten
und mit Papier wenn der Verkehrsminister
eine Langzeitstudie vorliegt
die sagt
die sagt der Straßenverkehr wird immer
wichtiger für die Wirtschaft dann sagen
die Grünen das habt ihr euch doch wohl
schön gerechnet und wenn das
Umweltbundesamt eine Studie präsentiert
die sagt mit einem Tempolimit da ließe
sich doch ordentlich CO2 sparen dann
liefert die FDP gleich die gegenstudie
die sagt stimmt doch gar nicht auch der
fDP-Fraktionschef Christian dürr lässt
da nicht mit sich reden Tempolimit nein
bei diesem ganzen Konflikten e-fuels
Tempolimit schnellerer Straßenbau landet
man immer wieder bei einem Grundkonflikt
der Kern des Streits und auch der Grund
warum sie jetzt 30 Stunden im Kanzleramt
gestritten haben und danach viele
richtig sauer sind
[Musik]
angesichts der Krise in dem
Verkehrssektor der am meisten emittiert
momentan über das was er darf ist es für
uns unbegreiflich dass der Kern des
Klimaschutzes in Deutschland das
Klimaschutzgesetz jetzt gestützt wurde
seit 2019 gilt das
bundesklimaschutzgesetz in dem gibt es
bislang sogenannte sektorziele
Landwirtschaft Bauen und Wohnen und
Verkehr da wird überall viel CO2
ausgestoßen und für alle diese Sektoren
ist so eine Art Treppe nach unten
festgelegt also wie viel CO2 muss der
Bereich bis 2030 einsparen damit wir
unsere Klimaziele schaffen seid es diese
sektorziele gibt ist der Verkehrsbereich
da der große loser dessen Sektor Ziel
wurde nur einmal erreicht 2020 als alle
wegen Corona zu Hause geblieben sind
jetzt steigt der Ausstoß aber sogar
wieder und die Lücke wird immer krasser
die neuesten Zahlen gab es jetzt gerade
im März die Mission im Verkehrsbereich
sind um eine Millionen Tonnen gestiegen
auf 148 Millionen Tonnen das heißt wir
haben hier eine
super Shooting im Verkehrsbereich im
Jahr 2022 von gut neun Millionen Tonnen
ja wenn man also over shootet dann muss
man bislang Sofortmaßnahmen liefern um
irgendwie doch noch das Ziel zu
erreichen und hier fängt das an mit der
Wut auf whisting im letzten Jahr wurde
ihm nämlich schon mal gesagt du musst
mehr machen deswegen hat ein ziemlich
spät eine Art ja so eine Art
Maßnahmenpaket vorgelegt wenn man das so
nennen kann und die die das Paket auf
Wirksamkeit prüfen müssen ja die haben
das in der Luft zerrissen das Programm
sei Zitat schon im Ansatz ohne Anspruch
wir sind selber sagt zu viele
klima-maßnahmen das kann er einfach
nicht bringen
[Musik]
ich muss abwägen zwischen der schnellen
Erreichung von Klimaschutzzielen
einerseits und den
Mobilitätsanforderungen und auch der
Akzeptanz der Gesellschaft für Maßnahmen
andererseits bissing und seine FDP
wollen weg vom systemsektor Ziele und
haben das jetzt nach langem bohren auch
geschafft die Begründung den Klima ist
doch egal wo das CO2 herkommt lieber
alles zusammenrechnen ja und dann gucken
das sei weniger kompliziert so darüber
haben grün und FDP Monate lang
gestritten ja was die SPD da genau will
das wusste man leider gar nicht dass
Gegenargument der Grünen wenn keine
verbindlichen sektorziele mehr da sind
dann kommt zum Beispiel der Verkehr doch
nie raus aus seinem co2-loch man löst
die Klimakrise am Ende ja nicht dadurch
dass man einfach versucht sie weg zu
definieren und das wäre es ja wenn man
die Situation Ziele aufgibt nicht mehr
hinschauen löst noch kein Problem ja und
jetzt ist klar die FDP hat sich dadurch
gesetzt mit der Hilfe der SPD das alte
System der sektoriele kommt weg dafür
gibt es eine Zitat
dieser übergreifende und mehrjährige
Gesamtrechnung die FDP spricht von einem
Paradigmenwechsel Umweltverbände aber
sind entsetzt im Südeuropa ist bereits
jetzt im März eine Dürre wir sehen die
Extremwetterereignisse in Neuseeland USA
angesichts dessen ist es für mich
unbegreiflich wie die Ampel die
Beschlüsse zum Klimaschutz eher
Schwächen schwächer macht als stärker
jetzt müssen die Grünen der eigenen
Basis irgendwie erklären dass es die
sektorziele auf die sie doch so großen
Wert gelegt haben so bald nicht mehr
gibt dafür aber
144 schnell gebaute Straßenprojekte die
wollten sie ja auch nicht da sind wir
wie auch würde ich sagen bei den
Maßnahmen die im Verkehrsbereich
ergriffen worden nicht stolz drauf
Wissing sagt hätten sie das mit den
Sektor Zielen nicht geändert dann hätten
irgendwann Fahrverbote gedroht
ziemliches Schreckgespenst die Grünen
sagen jetzt die Ziele seien ja nicht
ganz weg nur eben anders und anders
verteilt Volker Wissing jedenfalls steht
als Verkehrsminister stellvertretend für
den wohl größten Grundkonflikt zwischen
FDP und Grünen und wird deshalb so hart
angegangen in den letzten Monaten haben
sich die Grünen richtig auf wissigen ja
muss sagen eingeschossen die
Parteivorsitzende Ricarda lang setzt ihn
mit einem Kleinkind gleich das immer
noch Bauklötze schmeißt wenn alle
anderen aufräumen das Wissen auf eine
Parteitag mal von Klima Blabla
gesprochen hat das passt da voll in das
Bild der Grünen ja und die FDP die
schießt zurück da heißt es die Grünen
müssten damit klar kommen dass ein FTP
Verkehrsminister eben FDP Akzente setzt
die Grünen haben aus guten Gründen nicht
das Verkehrsministerium die Grünen
können ihre Akzente setzen im Bereich
der Umweltpolitik im Bereich der
Klimaschutzpolitik aber es muss auch in
dieser Koalition jemanden geben der
darauf achtet dass eine
exportorientierte Wirtschaft einen
vernünftig funktionierenden
Verkehrssektor und es ist ja tatsächlich
so den Grünen waren andere Ministerien
wichtiger Anton Hofreiter wer eigentlich
wahnsinnig gern Verkehrsminister
geworden soll aber so heißes hinter den
Kulissen nicht so richtig gut verhandelt
haben dass das den Grünen mal weh tun
würde das haben schon nach den
Koalitionsverhandlungen einige
vorhergesagt wir sind weiter eine
autozentrierte Republik wir haben wenig
drin bis gar nichts drin zum Thema
Verkehrswende und jetzt zu sagen okay in
FDP Minister wird Verkehrsminister das
finde ich schon
schwierig warum die Grünen so ticken
steckt bei Ihnen ja schon im Namen
Priorität hat der Klimaschutz
interessanter sind die Beweggründe der
FDP warum setzt die FDP so aufs Auto und
will nicht so tiefgreifende Änderungen
wie die Grünen sie fordern erstens das
ganze Thema triggert FDP man kann sagen
Grundgefühle auf keinen Fall soll die
Wirtschaft leiden und überhaupt alles
was nach Regulierung oder Vorschrift
riecht ja das provoziert FDP
Abwehrreflexe zweitens und das ist echt
nicht zu unterschätzen das Thema Auto
zieht Christian Lindner und die FDP
sehen hier einen Gewinner Thema für sich
und nach dem vielen vergeigten
Landtagswahlen gilt intern die Lösung
von oben alles was Punkte bringt nach
vorne bitte und die Zahlen geben Ihnen
ja recht Beispiel Verbrenner aus da will
eine Mehrheit der Deutschen genauso
wenig wie die FDP dass das kommt die
Mehrheit der Deutschen würde sich am
ersten auch wieder in Benziner zulegen
E-Autos sinken in der Beliebtheit ja und
auch ein Blick in unsere Community auf
Youtube zeigt viele User finden den von
Wissing und von der FDP richtig da gibt
es Kommentare wie den hier die deutsche
Automobilindustrie brauchen wir für
unseren Wohlstand weiter so Herr Wissing
klar aber es gibt auch andere nach
hotelsteuer nun das Porsche Privileg
schreibt dieser User das Auto Thema
jedenfalls liefert der FDP vieles wonach
sie sich gerade richtig sehnt ein
populäres Thema um das eigene Profil zu
schaffen außerdem eine Möglichkeit die
Grünen als verbotspartei zu schmähen ja
jetzt haben die Grünen gerade wirklich
viele Kröten schlucken müssen bei den
efuels hat Volker Wissing seine
Extrawurst bekommen bei der Kernfrage
der sektorziele hat sich die FDP
durchgesetzt ja und Straßen werden auch
schneller gebaut kann sein dass die
akute Wissing gut irgendwann abhebt aber
der Kern der bleibt ja da arbeiten zwei
Parteien zusammen die gerade im
Verkehrsbereich meistens das Gegenteil
der anderen Partei wollen nur dass der
eine gerade die Ansagen macht
was meint ihr brauchen wir die radikale
verkehrswände so wie es die Grünen
wollen oder seid ihr da eher auf der
Seite der FDP schreibt und diskutiert
gerne in den Kommentaren in unserem
Format Kontext könnt ihr mehr erfahren
über eine andere Großbaustelle im
Verkehrsbereich die Probleme mit der
Deutschen Bahn ihr alle habt sie und
hier erfahrt ihr warum und schaut gerne
auch weitere Folgen von politics es
lohnt sich vielen Dank für euer
Interesse und bis bald